bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes voici les
titres de ce mardi 30 mars
en février le chômage concernait près de
74 me lis vinoy pour la catégorie a pour
l'endiguer de nombreuses initiatives
locales sont lancés dans cette édition
focus sur coup d'envoi à saint germain
en laye qui accompagne les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi vers la création
d'entreprise
et puis sur l'entrepreneuriat pour tous
programmes portés à saint quentin en
yvelines en 2020 environ 1300 agressions
menaces ou insulte contre des élus ont
été recensés les mères sont souvent
démunis face à cette question des
incivilités pour les aider la
gendarmerie des yvelines propose une
formation et hier sur le sujet c'était à
magny les hameaux
et puis les tensions ravivées entre
usagers et riverains de l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble les mésententes porte
sur les conditions d'utilisation du site
qui faisait l'objet d'une réunion hier
avec la préfecture des yvelines les
riverains dénoncent l'augmentation du
trafic sur place responsable de
nombreuses nuisances sonores et depuis
hier une délégation spéciale est
installé à chevreuse pour gérer les
affaires comme une aide dans la les
affaires courantes dans la commune cela
fait suite à l'annulation du dernier
scrutin des municipales et c'est en
attendant un nouveau scrutin dans la
commune
interview à suivre dans ce journal
[Musique]
il envisage de s'exprimer demain soir
d'après les informations de plusieurs
médias emmanuel macron pourrait prendre
la parole dans une allocution
un conseil de défense sanitaire est
prévu plus tôt dans la journée 10 jours
après le déclenchement de la mesure du
confinement dans certains départements
dont ceux de l'ile-de-france au menu
notamment le maintien ou non de
l'ouverture des écoles allonger la durée
des vacances de printemps est une
hypothèse avancée de plus en plus et
depuis plusieurs semaines le taux
d'incidence chez les jeunes explose il a
doublé depuis la début mars pour les 0 9
ans et les 10 19 ans dans le même temps
la vaccination contre le colis de 19 se
poursuit et prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur dans les yvelines est depuis
lundi trois nouveaux centres ont ouvert
dans le département dans les communes de
chatou conflans sainte honorine et des
l'isi villacoublay ils fonctionneront la
semaine voir les week-ends
ces trois nouveaux sites viennent
s'ajouter aux 13 déjà existant portant
le nombre total de centre a16 dans le
département dans les yvelines d'ailleurs
au 29 mars
cent quarante mille quatre cent soixante
trois personnes ont été primés vacciner
au plus de 75 ans et aux plus de 65 ans
avec comorbidités sont venus s'ajouter
également depuis quelques jours les plus
de 70 ans près de 11000 rendez vous sont
prévus cette semaine pour une première
vaccination sur le territoire et environ
8000 pour une seconde injection
dans ce contexte épidémique difficile
encore plus de se lancer dans la
création d'entreprise à la ruche de
saint germain en laye et dix personnes
éloignées de l'emploi sont accompagnés
par des professionnels pendant plusieurs
mois quel statut choisir comment trouver
à ses clients qu'elle locaux autant de
questions auxquelles la ruche a tenté de
répondre et on voit tout ça dans le
reportage d'astrid bergère comment
entreprendre des yvelinois éloignés de
l'emploi sont accompagnés gratuitement
jusqu'au mois de juin par la ruche de
saint germain en laye pour créer leur
entreprise
le projet en fait c'est le programme qui
s'appelle le coup d'envoi qu'un
programme d'incubation nous accompagner
entre janvier et juin dix entrepreneurs
qui ont neuf projets puisqu'il ya un
binôme
l'idée c'est de les amener à structurer
leur projet a vraiment développé l'idée
qu'ils ont en tête de tester sur le
terrain
et puis voilà de vraiment pérenniser
leur projet à long terme sur le
territoire
les entrepreneurs et les projets sont
très variés odile elle souhaite créer
des groupes de parole pour les personnes
ayant besoin d'un thérapeute mais qui
n'en n'ont pas les moyens
être ensemble au sein d'une promotion
permet entre autres les change d'idée
paru chez elle m'amène plein de choses
c'est à dire que par le travail la
solidarité qui a déjà entre les acteurs
de la ruche et les acteurs qui sont dans
la promotion coup d'envoi je veux dire
on oeuvre on bouillonne ensemble poids
vue rare
à mener notre projet à terme et tous les
ateliers qui sont proposés sont vraiment
pertinent et soutenant ces projets sont
pour certains des reconversions et pour
d'autres un début de carrière manaré
capot de jeunes des mureaux ont lancé
une gamme de tisanes local est artisanal
à base d'orties et ils ont une idée
précise de leur projet sur le long terme
on souhaiterait devenir une marque de
bar à tisanes ou en fait on viendrait
prendre le café ou le latina de chez
nous et en même temps bénéficié
d'ateliers comme des séminaires des
master class pour avoir vraiment toutes
les clés en main pour s'approprier
retrouver son pouvoir d'agir à son tour
puisque nous on veut être fédérateur de
cercle vertueux mais programme coup
d'envoi est parrainée cette année par
frédéric avare directeur des projets
innovants par l'île de france chez
orange autres programmes vers la
création d'entreprise porté cette fois
ci sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous l'objectif
constituer une communauté de quinze
porteurs de projets qui vont bénéficier
d'une formation de 3 semaines et d'un
accompagnement complet pendant cinq mois
et ce entre mai et novembre 2021 pour ce
faire l'agglomération a uni ses forces
et une association qui s'appelle et
déterminé pour en parler d'eux invité
nicolas d'envié bonsoir bonsoir par
visioconférence vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et de l'apprentissage
je rappelle également que vous êtes le
maire de la verrière est également en
visioconférence toujours nadine nadir
gailly bonsoir vous êtes le référent sur
saint quentin en yvelines pour
l'association les déterminer où commence
justement avec vous en quelques mots
quel est le but de votre association
les déterminer une association qui a été
créée donc en 2015 par le président
fondateur moussa camara qui a pour but
principal de démocratiser
l'entrepreneuriat dans les quartiers
prioritaires dans un premier temps est
justement de pouvoir penser à travers un
programme d'accompagnement complet une
offre de formation à destination de ses
porteurs de projets association qui est
présent dans toute la france ce type de
projet l'entrepreneuriat pour tous a pu
être aussi mené sur sur d'autres
territoires
totalement donc cette association a déjà
fait ses preuves sur le territoire
régional en ile de france est
effectivement avec l'aide de tous nos
partenaires historiques et notamment des
pays france
nous avons pensé à un déploiement de ces
formations à l'échec du territoire
national notamment à toulouse à lyon à
montpellier à marseille à lille rouen
robes et nantes
actuellement on prépare aussi bordeaux
le havre est effectivement nous avons
uni nos forces pour proposer une
formation sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines nicolas dainville
pour l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pourquoi justement s'appuyer
sur l'expertisé de cette association les
déterminer mais écoutez vous l'avez dit
c'est une association qui est une
expérience à près de 265 même un peu
plus aujourd'hui promotion donc c'est
une expérience et une vie d'associations
qui portent de très belles valeurs liées
à l'entrepreneuriat qui est une
expertise qui est reconnu par un certain
nombre d'autres communes et donc c'est
un gage de sérieux
c'est une garantie pour nous que de
faire appel aux terminée eh bien ce sera
une occasion de former nos jeunes à
l'entrepreneuriat de manière extrêmement
rigoureuse sérieuse et donc c'est pour
ça qu'on fait appel à cette belle
association il ya un souci pour
l'agglomération de fait rappelle
justement des démarches innovantes pour
l'emploi il y a par exemple deux ans une
expérimentation avait été menée sur le
territoire autour de l'entreprise
éphémère où une cinquantaine de
demandeurs d'emploi avaient pu faire
partie de cette expérience
écoutez à saint quentin en yvelines ont
une terre d'innovation on a les plus
belles entreprises du monde de sodexo à
airbus en passant par thalès ou renault
on a aussi créé activité un ensemble
d'entrepreneurs qui ont soif
d'entreprendre conçoivent de créer
conçoivent d'innover et il faut qu'on
les accompagne
on a créé l'incubateur ski cube c'est
donc l'objectif de cet incubateur de de
permettre de se faire réaliser ses
projets entrepreneuriaux
mais on a aussi des entrepreneurs qui
sont souvent éloignés des dispositifs
traditionnels dead à la création
d'entreprises qui sont dans nos
quartiers nos quartiers dits en priorité
de la ville et donc il faut aussi
qu'on les accompagne pour pas qu'on les
laisse tomber on a sept quartiers
prioritaires de la ville sur 51 c'est à
peu près 15 % de la population
on a ça représente 11% de la création
d'entreprise et ce sont des entreprises
qui je dirais malheureusement sont
souvent des auto entreprises et sur des
secteurs très particulier les vtc
la restauration est donc tout l'enjeu
c'est d'avoir des entreprises qui
grandissent davantage et qui soit sur
des secteurs plus variés et donc on va
s'accompagner sur les déterminée pour y
arriver
justement nadir gaguie de créer une
émulation autour de l'emploi de la
création d'entreprise pourquoi c'est
important
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
finalement si vous ne donnez pas un coup
de pouce peut-être assez à ces personnes
certain talent ne pourrait pas être
dénicher des créations d'entreprises ne
pourrait pas se faire entre autres en
fait on part du postulat simple que dans
le quartier il y a des talents plus
globalement dans tous les domaines mais
notamment dans la crise dans la création
dans la dynamique de développement
économique
donc effectivement ce qu'on se dit c'est
que nous avons nous aussi eu des
parcours d'entrepreneurs ou n'a pas été
simple sympa et écoute a été plutôt
compliqué non pas pour des raisons
d'argent mais par des modérés nom de
code et de réseaux est l'objectif
effectivement c'est aujourd'hui avec
cette expérience cette expertise plus de
23 promotion c'est te dire que si on a
la possibilité d'apporter une main
tendue à ces entrepreneurs à ses
porteurs de projets ces femmes et ces
hommes de ces territoires
on le fait avec grand plaisir et ça
participera activement au développement
économique aussi de tous ces territoires
très concrètement ce sera gratuit
comment va se dérouler le programme de
préciser tout à l'heure il y aura quinze
porteurs de projets accompagnés trois
semaines de formation intensive et un
accompagnement de cinq mois entre mai et
novembre 2021 mais concrètement que
va-t-il y avoir justement dans cet
accompagnement
la formation dont vous l'avez dit elle
s'est déroulée en gros en six mois
répartis en deux temps donc trois
semaines intensives qui vont nous
permettre justement de travailler sur le
potentiel du panther et de la porteuse
de projets l'idée c'est de formaliser le
projet de le structurer via
l'intelligence collective de aussi se
tirer tous les uns vers les autres et
bien évidemment de théâtre en totale
adéquation avec la personne que nous
sommes et sont creusées et ensuite on va
pendant les cinq mois qui suivent avec
les partenaires de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement
notamment sur youtube
accompagner les porteurs de projets sur
les blocs de compétences spécifiques à
l'entrepreneuriat l'étude de marché les
business plan business model la
stratégie de communication stratégiques
comme un marketing comment elle est
recherchée un premier client la levée de
fonds toutes ces sujets qui sont
extrêmement importants et primordiaux
pour pouvoir être outil un maximum dans
ce rôle de chef d'entreprise nicolas
mainville quels objectifs se fixe
l'agglomération justement sur sur ce
projet qui va être portée
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous mais à
écouter vous l'avez dit une première
promotion de 15 personnes
donc ça fera peu près 30 créateurs
d'entreprise accompagnés sur une année
savez vous parliez l'association est
déterminé par libé des modèles et c'est
vrai que dans nos quartiers on met
souvent en avant les artistes et
sportifs
c'est très très bien ils font rayonner
la france dans le monde mais on met pas
suffisamment en avant nos entrepreneurs
et y en a énormément des artisans des
chefs d'entreprise qui se lancent qui
partent de rien qui arrive à créer et à
innover il faut aussi qu'on l'ait qu'on
compte qu'on les mette en valeur parce
que ce sont de très beaux modèles de
très beaux exemples pour la jeunesse et
donc c'est aussi ce qui nous a attirés
sur l'association dé déterminer qui est
porté par des entrepreneurs qui ont cru
en leurs rêves et qui ont eu l'audace de
tout faire pour essayer de le réaliser
des questions très pratiques pour
terminer qui peut candidater et comment
justement candidater pour faire partie
d'entrepreneuriat pour tous
alors je parlerai juste peut-être sur la
partie des ambassadeurs qu'on va
identifier des tiers de confiance qui
vont essayer de d'identifier ses
créateurs de projets et peut-être que la
saison les détermine il est peut
compléter mon propos totalement à l'idée
c'est de mettre à disposition donc via
un site de pouvoir candidater via un
questionnaire extrêmement rapide tu va
permettre d'identifier les porteurs de
projets qui sont intéressés par la suite
nous les recontacte aurons nous les
inviterons un jury de sélection qui
permettra de étoffer le projet de deux
paires précisé l'engagement du porteur
de projet dans le projet et à partir de
là les personnes retenues pourront être
invités à débuter la formation très
rapidement et pour plus d'informations
rendez vous sur le lien qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran je précise d'ailleurs
qu'un webinaire d'information elle sera
organisée le lundi 3 mai autour de ce
projet merci à vous de nicolas et
dainville et nadir yaghi d'être venu en
parler dans ce journal
dans le reste de l'actualité il sera
jugé du 20 au 22 octobre tribunal
judiciaire de versailles
le footballeur karim benzema comparaîtra
pour complicité de tentative de chantage
dans la sphère de la sextape de son
ancien coéquipier en équipe de france
mathieu valbuena des faits qui remontent
à juin 2015
les peines encourues pour le joueur de
33 ans cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de
75000 euros d'amendé
quatre autres personnes sont poursuivis
également pour tentative de chantage
on apprend par ailleurs que le parquet
de versailles a requis une peine de 2
millions d'euros contre ikea france dans
le procès qui se tient à la cour
correctionnelle la filiale du géant
suédois de la décoration est accusé
d'avoir espionné recueilli des
informations confidentielles sur
plusieurs centaines de salariés et des
candidats à l'embauché et ce pendant
plusieurs années est le parquet a requis
également un an de prison un an de
prison ferme contre l'un des anciens pdg
de la filiale procès jusqu'au 2 avril à
versailles au chapitre politique les
élections régionales prévues les 13 et
20 juin prochain laurent saint martin le
candidat franciliens pour la majorité
présidentielle s'est rendu au campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité située à guyancourt un
déplacement de campagne pour présenter
ses mesures en matière de mobilité
eléonore sinoquet de la mobilité propre
et de l'automobile plus électrique ce
sont les propositions du candidat l'art
public en marche à la présidence de la
région ile de france laurent saint
martin pour sa campagne il était en
déplacement lundi 29 mars au campus des
services de l'automobile et des
mobilités de guyancourt sacoche toutes
les cases de ma campagne des enjeux de
formation des enjeux de transition
écologique c'est d'abord un exercice d'
écoutes qui est le mien aujourd'hui mais
aussi celui de confronter mes
propositions
nous avons parlé avec l'ensemble des
formateurs de la pertinence justement
d'accompagner encore davantage via la
prime à la conversion via notamment tous
les outils que la région demain pourrait
faire en plus pour pouvoir non seulement
aidé la formation professionnelle mais
aussi aider dans le sens de la filière
automobile propre demain le candidat a
donc visité l'ensemble du campus qui
forme aux métiers de l'automobile mais
également de la moto ou encore du vélo
une visite appréciée par la directrice
qui souhaite que sa filière ne soit pas
oubliée dans ces élections régionales
c'est une période
qui suscite en fait à ce type de
rencontre est pour nous c'est important
en fait que le le monde politique soient
conscients de nos enjeux comprennent
également les investissements des
collectivités territoriales et bas nous
accompagne sur l'ensemble de nos projets
pour nous c'est important de faire
entendre la voix des services
automobiles et on ajoute désormais le
plus souvent possible de la mobilité
parce que le vic l'automobile a souvent
mauvaise presse alors même qu'on peut
aujourd'hui développer tous cas mobilité
douce
et puis véhicules hybrides rechargeables
électriques etc
malgré la crise sanitaire le campus des
services de l'automobile et des
mobilités continuent de former ces
apprentis et alternant une formation
d'autant plus importante au vu des
enjeux futurs de cette filière les
autres candidats en ile-de-france audrey
pulvar pour le parti socialiste et
jordan bardella pour le rassemblement
national clémentine autain pour la
france insoumise et julien bayou pour
europe ecologie les verts et valérie
pécresse la présidente sortante de la
région n'a pour l'heure pas déclaré sa
candidature officiellement les élections
départementales sont également prévues
aux mêmes dates que les régionales les
13 et 20 juin prochains
ces scrutins ont déjà été reporté une
fois en raison du contexte sanitaire de
mars à juin et la question d'un nouveau
report se pose désormais avec
l'émergence d'une troisième vague à ce
propos le conseil scientifique a rendu
son avis lire lundi il ne tranche pas
sur la question mais considère qu'un
nouveau report permettrait de faire
baisser le niveau de risque le conseil
sanitaire laisse cependant le choix au
gouvernement de trancher à chevreuse une
délégation spéciale a été installée en
début de semaine par la sous-préfète
hélène geronimi
elle aura pour charge de gérer les
affaires courantes dans la commune après
la décision du conseil d'état de
confirmer l'annulation de la dernière
élection municipale à chevreuse en
attendant de nouvelles élections le 9 et
le 16 mai prochain trois personnes vont
composer cette délégation spéciale parmi
lesquels jacques le lieu aux ancien
maire de magny les hameaux qui explique
son rôle au micro d'eléonore sinoquet
mon rôle ce n'est pas encore le même air
classiques
si je suis là pour régler les affaires
compte administratif est exceptionnel
lorsqu'il ya un problème donc au niveau
du centre de toulouse fera donc j'évite
donc le ski quelques chaussures
cheuvreux le sien n'est à prendre mes
responsabilités j'ai rencontré lundi
dernier donc au niveau des trois
personnes désignées par effectivement
donc préfectures et sous-préfectures et
donc tout ça tourne bien on s'entend
bien non compteront bien et moi se
partager la tâche moins évidemment
[Musique]
j'ai signalé au procès donc je passerai
que finalement j'ai appréhendé les
dimanches élections au moins de même
dont on constate aujourd'hui où on re
même que donc comme vous le savez que
finalement donc que l'état n'a pas pris
ses dispositions finales en ce qui
concerne les élections de juin prévus
pour les départementales et régionales
en 2020 environ lee 300 agressions
menaces ou insulte contre des élus ont
été recensés en france un chiffre en
large augmentation par rapport à l'année
précédente pour les accompagner face aux
incivilités le groupement de gendarmerie
des yvelines a donné des conseils à ses
élus pour gérer ce genre de situation
dans leur commune une première journée
de formation a eu lieu ce lundi 29 mars
à magny les hameaux justin brasier ils
font parfois face à des comportements
revendicatif violents ou difficile lundi
29 mars une trentaine d'élus se sont
rendus au centre blaise pascal pour
suivre une formation de gestion des
incivilités les situations fréquentes
aujourd'hui il ya un niveau d'exigence
élevé de la part des habitants avec un
niveau de tolérance particulièrement bas
et le maire et et dans l'entre-deux
donc on vient le voir avec une demande
toujours urgente pressante et avec une
solution apporter immédiatement
la formation a été proposée à l'ensemble
des élus des yvelines
des représentants de proximité amené à
voir ce genre de situation au quotidien
aujourd'hui on a des des élus qui
viennent de saint germain en laye où de
l'ouest du département où tout juste à
côté de de magny les hameaux on a des
collègues du mini 110 ou de voisins par
exemple qui sont là
l'objectif est que au fur et à mesure
des prochaines dates aussi on puisse
justement à couvrir l'ensemble du
territoire pour permettre à tous les
élus qu'il souhaite d'avoir cette
information objectif de la formation
donner des clés aux élus pour éviter
qu'une situation ne dégénère apaiser le
dialogue ou encore trouver des solutions
verbal on a tous un vécu donc on a tous
des bonnes idées mais c'est dans des
situations le stress est présent c'est
vraiment avoir les petits outils simples
pour agir autant que possible face aux
situations difficiles cette première
réunion s'inscrit dans un cycle d'autres
formations sur les incivilités et la
cyber sécurité devrait avoir lieu
prochainement
et puis il ya deux ans nous les
recevrons sur ce plateau pour parler des
nouvelles conditions d'utilisation de
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble les
associations de riverains et
d'utilisateurs avaient à l'époque
travailler pour réduire les nuisances
sonores provoquées les week-ends et
jours fériés mais depuis quelques
semaines à mésentente est de retour ce
lundi une réunion de la commission
consultative de l'environnement s'est
tenu les riverains ne sont toujours pas
convaincus par le projet présenté les
précisions de mélanie poké 120000
mouvement chaque année et un pic à 135
milles pour l'année 2019
plus que le nombre c'est le bruit lié
aux décollages et atterrissages qui
crispe certaines associations de riz
brun dominant a été marqué sur prendra
pas part effectivement cet effet qu vide
c'était ce que vit qui ont eu certes une
une phase très calme pendant la période
de confinement le code mars avril qui
s'est terminée par une par une erreur il
monte un sens avec une reprise d'un
trafic incroyablement nerveux 1
c'est un constat d'échec parce que en
fin de compte ont depuis des lustres on
se bat pour essayer d'améliorer la
situation de réduire les nuisances
sonores et en même temps donc bien
qu'ils aient eu des discussions
intéressantes aussi avec les usagers
malgré ça en fait le trashy cas continue
d'augmenter et ce qu'on constate aussi
qu'il continue d'augmenter mais pour
l'union des airs au club de toussus qui
rassemble sept aéro clubs et près de
1000 pilotes l'aérodrome de toussus le
noble doit continuer ça
sion on pense que la réduction du nombre
de mouvements et pas du tout la bonne
approche
notre activité est essentiel pour
l'avenir du pays d'avenir aéronautique
et du pays
nous formons non seulement des pilotes
de loisirs mais nous formons aussi des
pilotes qui poursuivent leur formation
pour acquérir une formation des pilotes
professionnels les associations de
riverains souhaitent que les mouvements
soient réduits et que se développe
l'utilisation d'avions que bruyant une
réunion s'est tenue ce lundi 29 mars
avec la préfecture des yvelines pour
présenter le projet d'arrêté fixant les
conditions d'utilisation de l'aérodrome
non satisfaits les riverains se sont
positionnés contre usagers et
collectivités ont voté pour voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant ont retrouvé le
7 8 culture présentée par justine
brasier belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]